un dimanche à la campagne version bio
c'est sur l'exploitation de sophie
arnould à olivet l'idée de mettre en
avant la consommation de produits issus
de l'agriculture biologique qui a bondi
pendant le confinement
le fait de voir des gens vraiment si
c'est qu'ils travaillent dans ma région
ça me fait vraiment du bien de pouvoir
être en contact avec eux j'ai pris des
adresses et c'est comme ça je pourrais
me déplacer plus tard pour faire mes
courses sans avoir besoin d'aller dans
une grande distribution et d'acheter un
produit je sais pas qui vient d'un autre
pays même si les européens ici on peut
acheter bien sûr mais aussi s'informer
grâce à des conférences en plein air et
puis le consommateur peut aussi mettre
la main à la pâte
moi j'ai une cueillette de fruits et
légumes bio les gens c'était leur
échappatoire il avait besoin d'oxygène
et venez chez nous voilà pour du
réconfort et se faire plaisir à bien
cuisiner si l'engouement est là les
acteurs du bio considère que le pouvoir
politique actuelle ne tient pas ses
promesses retard dans le paiement des
aides et objectif de 15 % de surfaces
cultivées en bio l'an prochain
abandonner le gouvernement il est trop
timide
les trop timides les aides aujourd'hui
ne vont pas assez vers ses producteurs
bio ils ont besoin d'être accompagnés il
ya la problématique de la conversion et
la conversion en bio c'est pendant trois
ans que ça que ça a duré pendant trois
ans ils produisent mois de prêt
produisent moins donc ils perdent du
chiffre d'affaires donc il faut les
aider
en attendant la filière bio espère que
la demande va continuer à croître pour
soutenir la production locale